Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Was ist eigentlich los in der französischen Liga? Das wollen wir heute klären mit David Fougier de Pont-Lévoix von 390 unter anderem und intimer Frankreich-Kennner hier in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 97. David, schön, dass du mal wieder mit dabei bist.
Ja, schön, dass ich dabei sein darf. Guten Abend und hallo liebe Hörer.
Und Hörerinnen natürlich.
Und Hörerinnen, ja. Aber neulich hat tatsächlich jemand Hörer und Hörerinnen gegrüßt. Und es ist mir aufgefallen, dass das gar nicht so oft vorkommt im Rasenfunk. Und ja, ich fand das sehr nett. Hab mich gefreut, ich hab mich angesprochen gefühlt. Insofern, hallo jeder draußen.
Ja, ich hab's mir antrainiert, immer beide schlechter zu nennen. Aber tatsächlich, manche haben es gestern noch nicht so drauf. Es hat sich auch noch nicht so weit verbreitet über andere Podcasts.
Nee, ich meinte generell einfach, die Hörer zu grüßen. Also meistens, wenn du einen Gast hast, begrüßt der dich.
Ah, deswegen hast du dich auch angesprochen, gefühlt. Okay, ja, das stimmt tatsächlich. Ja, richtig. Hab ich nicht angesprochen, gefühlt. Das ist so ein nettes Winken des Gastes ins nicht vorhandene oder nicht sichtbare Auditorium. Mag ich eigentlich ganz gerne. Ich hab mir quasi mit dem Intro so eine Showtreppe gebaut. Und die komm ich runter. Und dann brüllt mich Norbi Dickel da weg im letzten Schlusskonferenz-Intro. Aber ansonsten.
Aber ich freu mich riesig, dass ich über die französische Liga spreche. Ja, weil sonst will niemand mit mir sprechen.
Grüße an der Stelle an so einem Nebenprojekt von dir. So ein kleines Nischenprojekt namens 390.de. An der Stelle noch mal sehr empfohlen. Ja, wir wollen über die Liga sprechen. Und da ich weiß, dass du über beide Ohren voll bepackt bist mit Wissen zu dieser Liga, wollen wir auch gar nicht viel Zeit verlieren. Wir gucken uns mal die Tabelle an. Und ich greife mir ein paar Vereine raus, bevor du freestylen darfst. Ganz oben, Thron, Paris, Saint-Germain. Die haben noch keinen einzigen Punkt abgegeben. Sie haben die meisten Tore erzielt, 32 nach neun Spielen. Sie haben die wenigsten Tore kassiert, sechs. Mbappé und Neymar führen gemeinsam die französische Torjägerliste an. Das ist ja ultra langweilig. Und liegt das jetzt nur am Kader? Oder kann man daraus auch schließen, dass Thomas Tuchel da einen sehr guten, gelungenen Einstand feiert?
Also ich hab mir jetzt tatsächlich zur Vorbereitung auf das Gespräch mit dir nochmal das Kapitel von Tuchel in Tobi Eschers Buch, Rezettas Stegen, durchgelesen, weil ich nochmal meinen Eindruck abgleichen wollte mit Tuchel, so wie ich ihn wahrgenommen habe. Und ich war sehr dankbar, dass tatsächlich in dem Kapitel auch durchaus rauskam, dass Tuchel jemand ist, der ein passionierter Mensch des Fußballs ist, aber nicht unbedingt immer einfach in der Kommunikation, sondern dass er gerne mit Menschen trainiert, die vollführend Fußball brennen und auch zeigen, dass sie das wollen. Und mit Funktionären zu tun hat, die vollführend Fußball brennen. Und insofern konnte man sich ja durchaus fragen, naja, ist der da eigentlich in Paris an der richtigen Stelle, wo ein Neymar spielt, der bekanntlich lieber geprokt hat, als sich das Spiel anzuschauen, wo sie dann Meister wurden, da war er verletzt, wo ein Rabiot spielt, der sagt, nö, also als Ersatzspieler für die Nationalmannschaft, da hab ich keinen Bock, also auf der Warteliste, da tret ich lieber ganz von zurück, und wo der Präsident Al-Khalifi eigentlich der Tennis-Präsident des Katharischen Fußballverwaltens ist und so was. Also passt er dahin. Und es ging auch genauso los, wie man es befürchten hätte können, in der Transferphase.
Das heißt nur noch Vollkorn am Buffet, oder nee, nicht mal Vollkorn, das ist ja auch vielleicht wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Körner.
Ja, er hat den Trainingsraum vergrößert, damit alle zusammen trainieren können, also den Fitnessraum anscheinend.
Okay, das ist eine Insolvenz.
Nö, nee, nee, aber kommen wir gleich schon drauf. Aber was halt in der Transferphase, haben sie nicht das einkauft, was sie eigentlich gebraucht haben. Unter anderem, weil sie immer noch unter diesem Financial Fairplay-Schwert hingen. Sie mussten, ich glaube, für 64 Millionen haben sie Spieler verkauft und nur für 52 Millionen eingekauft. Wobei das, also die großen Knaller sind's jetzt halt dann irgendwie auch nicht, ne? Also Buffon, Kehrer, Bernat, noch irgendjemand. Genau, die größte Kononofarie, Tupo Moting. Und was sie eigentlich brauchen, ist ein defensiver Mittelfeldspieler, ein Sechser, ein Arbeiter, weil Motta ist gegangen. Und da haben sie niemanden. Da haben sie Rabioda, da haben sie Verratti, das sind beides eher kreative Leute. Tuchel hat anfangs versucht, oder Macinus da ein bisschen in die Mitte zu ziehen. Und eigentlich haben sie keine... Da fehlt ihnen eindeutig was. Das hast du auch gegen Liverpool gesehen. Das war ja vermutlich das Spiel, was einige auch mitbekommen haben jetzt von den Hörern. Hast du es gesehen?
32 Liverpool.
Genau. Und auffällig war unter anderem eben, Neymar und Bapé arbeiten nicht nach hinten. Und die Mannschaft zerfällt. Und das ist genau das, wie mit Emery damals, der auch gesagt hat, oh, ja, ich möchte der Mannschaft Pressing beibringen und dann ist nix draus geworden. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Trotz all dieser Nicklichkeiten und Schwierigkeiten, die man so auf dem Papier sieht, es klappt tatsächlich wunderbar. Und was mich am meisten überrascht, ist die absolut positive, das positive Bild von Tuchel. Sowohl in den Medien als anscheinend auch bei den Spielern. Also, die Lequip hatte Tuchel von ein paar Tagen oder Wochen, müsste schon wieder her sein. Eine Titelseite gewidmet, Überschriften mit, die Charme Offensive.
Also Charme oder Scharm?
Scharm. Scharm, ja, nee, Scharm.
Weitereinig, ob die so wortspielaffin sind, wie so manche deutsche Fußballmedien. Deswegen wollte ich lieber nachfragen.
Du meinst, wie so ein gewisser Podcast, der mit ein paar Waben hat. Ich hab noch nie Wortspiele gemacht.
Und die Charme Offensive hatten sie auch.
Genau, die Charme Offensive. Und was da rauskam, war unter anderem eben, dass es hieß, es hatte früher Grübchenbildung gegeben und es hätte Egos gegeben und das sei alles komplett weg. Weil Tuchel ganz nah bei den Spielern sei, er würde ganz viel mit ihnen reden. Alle würden sich von ihm wertgeschätzt fühlen. Er hat tatsächlich sehr, sehr viele junge Leute reingebracht. Auch das hatte Emmery durchaus immer wieder gesagt, hat es aber dann nicht getan. Weil, wie es hieß, die Profis dann sagten, Alter, ist die Kabine so voll. Da haben wir keinen Bock drauf. Und da sind tatsächlich Leute, Nsoki, Diaby, Dagbar, Wer, der junge Wer, der so und so. Die zum Teil 4-5 Einsätze hatten schon in der Saison.
Ach, Wahnsinn.
Also gar nicht so wenig. Ich bin tatsächlich etwas überrascht auch von Tuchel. Ich erinnere mich so nicht an ihn, zumindest nicht in seiner Dortmunder-Zeit. Ich habe jetzt auch auf Twitter mit ein paar Mainzern gesprochen, auch mit Stammgästen aus der Sendung Wortpiratinnen und so weiter. Und die haben gesagt, sie würden damals als Tuchel in Mainz, da sei er sehr wohl ein Menschenfänger, ein Charmeur gewesen. Also es gäbe da verschiedene Ansichten und so weiter, wie es ja immer so ist bei Menschen. Aber das sei durchaus was, was sie bestätigen könnten, das habe er wohl in sich gehabt und das finden sie nicht verwunderlich.
Und so sieht es dann auch bei PSG aus, aktuell zumindest. Andererseits hatten sie ja noch eine Niederlage erst in all den Spielen bisher, das war eben das angesprochene 2 zu 3, ansonsten lief ja alles wunderbar. Und jetzt auch das 6 zu 1 gegen Roter Stern war ja mehr als dominant und überzeugend. Das heißt, so eine richtige Schwäche, Phase oder Krise hat PSG ja auch noch nicht erlebt.
Ja, sie waren nicht in allen Spielen komplett beeindruckend. Neymar hat ihnen ziemlich den Schneid abgekauft, auch wenn sie am Ende gewonnen haben, der Aufsteiger. Auch Lyon hat trotz dieser 15-0-Klatsche jetzt am Wochenende, die erste Halbzeit war eigentlich gut von Lyon. Auch da haben sie wieder gepresst. Und Tuchel konnte nur Verratti aufstellen, weil Rabiot war gesperrt, musste Macchinos in die Mitte ziehen und Macchinos hat sich als nicht sehr pressingresistent rausgestellt, hat die Bälle dann weit und wuchtig nach vorne geschlagen. Es gab aber niemanden, der eigentlich im Kader ist, der weit nach vorne geschlagene Bälle gut annehmen kann. Dadurch sind sie so ein klein bisschen durchaus geschwommen. Also dieses 5 zu 0 in der zweiten Halbzeit voll verdient und Mbappé großartig. Aber du merkst schon nach wie vor, dass dieser Sechser fehlt. Was er gemacht hat, was er schlau von ihm war, ist Neymar zentral in die Mitte zu ziehen. Vorher war es ja dieser Dreiersturm, Cavalli, Neymar, Mbappé und Neymar spielt jetzt ein Spielgestalter, scheint sich da viel, viel wohler zu fühlen. Er arbeitet vor allem mit dem Mbappé sehr, sehr eng zusammen. Die scheinen sich sehr gut zu verstehen. Und gegen Nitzer ist Tuchel mit so einer Art 3-4-2-1 so fast zum Tannenbaum irgendwie aufgelaufen. Und hat es dadurch geschafft, dass auch das Team nicht zerfallen ist. Was früher immer ihr großes Problem war, dass die vordere Reihe losgestürmt ist und die hinterer Reihe verteidigt hat. Also du siehst schon auch, dass er da rumprobiert und versucht und seine taktischen Tuchel-Analytics-Fähigkeiten behalten lässt. Das sieht schon alles nicht so schlecht aus.
Thomas Tuchel, das Google Analytics unter den Fußballtrainern. Wie macht sich denn Gigi Buffon beim PSG?
Auch erstmal überraschend gut. Also das dürfte alles recht harmonisch sein. Ich meinte jetzt eher im Sinne von Egos und Zusammenhalt und Rivalitäten. Strengelang gibt es keine Klare Nummer 1. Möglicherweise werden Sie sich noch erinnern an das Volta-Spiel. Wie heißt das? Das Nations League-Spiel. Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Da hat Arreola im Tor ein paar Dinge herausgefischt. Er hat gezeigt, dass er ein durchaus guter Torwart ist. Und Buffon ist ja in der Champions League, war ja jetzt erstmal gesperrt. Das heißt, Tuchel hat auch bewusst gesagt, ich möchte Arreola gerne auch Spielpraxis in der Liga geben. Die haben sich jetzt so abgewechselt immer wieder mal. Also ich bin mal gespannt, wie das jetzt weitergeht. Natürlich hat Buffon Klasse und Erfahrung und alles, aber Arreola ist halt schon auch noch mal jünger und moderner. Und der ist nicht schlecht, der Junge. Also im Grunde, ja, streng genommen hättest du den Transfer möglicherweise nicht gebraucht. Vielleicht brauchst du ihn, um sozusagen Paris diesen Siegeswillen zu geben oder dieses psychologische Bild zu vermitteln. Jawohl, wir können Champions League. Ich glaube aber trotz allem immer noch nicht, dass sie für die Champions League höchsten Wein bereit sind, muss ich sagen.
Ja gut, aber da ist ja auch noch viel landhin. Vielleicht sehen wir dann auch noch mehr Tuchel im Fußball von PSG. Und für mich, da folge ich ganz der Linie meiner Antragt-Frankfurt-Freunde, für mich war Beauvon immer nur ein Ersatz für den abgegangenen Kevin Trapp.
Ja, in der L'équipe gab es einen Kommentar, vor kurzem gesagt nach, früher war bei Paris Saint-Exupéry noch was Spannendes. Da wusste man nicht genau, legt sich Trapp wie ein Ei ins Nest? Macht Aurier wieder irgendwelche Periscope-Sachen? Das war ja diese Sache, wo er damals über Laurent Blanc hergehetzt hat auf Periscope. Stimmt richtig. Das war ja fast so ein FC Hollywood sozusagen. Und jetzt ist alles so harmonisch, und es ist ja fürchterlich. Jetzt gewinnen sie die Meisterschaft auch noch ohne Skandälchen.
Wie ist denn da die Stimmung in Frankreich? Also acht Punkte Vorsprung nach neun Spieltagen, also fast ein Pünktchen Vorsprung pro Spieltag rausgearbeitet. Noch kein einziger Punkt Verlust, also kein Unentschieden, keine Niederlage. Dass es langweilig werden würde, könnte man schon annehmen. Aber ist man jetzt überrascht darüber, wie dominant PSG ist? Gibt es da irgendeine Hoffnung innerhalb der Liga? Oder haben die eh schon alle abgeschenkt und rechnen erst ab Platz zwei?
Also, weil ich jetzt nicht in Frankreich wohne, kann ich dir jetzt sozusagen den Klatsch aus den Bürofluren nicht sagen. Ich würde aber mal annehmen dadurch, dass Paris sowieso die ganzen letzten Jahre wie gesagt trotz diverser Schwächen immer gewonnen hat. Also wenn du auf die Tabelle schaust, musst du dir gar keine Illusionen machen. Überhaupt keine. Zumal es gibt noch nicht mal einen wirklich starken zweiten Herausforderer.
Was uns ja zum zweiten Herausforderer blinkt, dann lass uns doch direkt über die sprechen. Lille liegt auf Platz zwei. Zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden, sechs Siege, damit 19 Punkte. 8 Punkte Rückstand eben auf PSG, aber auch 3 Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 3 und Platz 4. Wie hat Lille das geschafft? Was müssen wir über Lille wissen?
Mit dem Roadrunner haben sie es geschafft.
Okay, definiere bitte. Oder ist es der Roadrunner? Aber dann hätte ich das schon auf Twitter gesehen.
Also du erinnerst dich an den Roadrunner. Was ist das? Looney Tunes, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, genau.
Dieser Vogel, der immer... Genau, map, map macht. Im deutschen macht er map, map. Im Französischen macht er beep, beep. Es ist ja jetzt modern geworden, dass Sturmreihen mit drei Buchstabenkötzeln abgekürzt werden. Finger mit Real und BBC an. Paris wollte ja nicht nachstehen und nannte seine Stürmer MCN, was keinerlei Sinn ergibt, aber es klang halt irgendwie cool.
Du, die USA mit statt Nefter USMCA. Also, es geht... Und die heißen beep oder wie?
Genau, der Rotronner heißt tatsächlich, der macht dich nur beep, der heißt auch beep, beep. Das heißt nicht Rolltronner, sondern heißt beep, beep. Und jetzt darfst du eben raten, was das Kürzel der drei... Offensivkräfte von Lille ist. Das sind Bamba, Ikone und Pepe. Und die wirbeln alles durcheinander. Also, das ist eine helle Freude. Streng genommen sind es noch nicht mal die... Also, es sind noch ein Stoßstürmer vorne dran, der Loic Remy. Aber Bamba und Pepe halt auf den Außen.
Und die sind ja noch wahnsinnig jung. Also Ikone ist 20, Bamba 22, Pepe 23.
Genau. Also Pepe kriegt auch jetzt schon die ganzen Meldungen mit sämtliche Großclubs schauen auf ihn drauf. Der war letzte Saison schon bei Lille. Da hat er überhaupt nicht gut performt. Bamba und Ikone sind neu dazugekommen. Die drei kommen ungefähr alle aus derselben Region. Verstehen sich ganz gut. Man muss dazu wissen, dass Lille vergangene Saison eine richtig richtige Seuchensaison hatte. Die standen im Grunde kurz vor dem Abstieg. Obwohl oder vielleicht weil sie gestartet waren mit einem ganz großspurigen Projekt, das sie ausgerufen hatten, dem LOSC Unlimited. LOSC ist die Abkürzung für Lille, Lille OSC. Das Ziel war, großartiger Fußball zu spielen, gepaart mit Talenten und wir wollen im 1. Jahr mindestens 5. und 2. Jahr mindestens 3. werden. Und sie hatten sich damals Bielsa geleistet als Trainer. Genau, das Missverständnis, der dann halt versucht hat, seinen Stil auf ein Team aufzupfropfen, das dafür offenbar nicht gemacht war und der auf PKs rumgepumpt hat und dann entlassen wurde. Und dann gab es Skandale mit den Spielern. Dann wurden Spieler in Nachtclubs erwischt. Und auch besagter PP wurde auf die Bank verbannt, weil er ein gefährliches Objekt zum Training mitgebracht hat. Und so weiter, und so weiter. Also großes, großes Chaos.
Großes Kino.
Großes Kino auch, ja. Und dann kam eben Galtier als neuer Trainer, der eigentlich eher den Ruf hat, na ja, etwas konservativ vorsichtigeren Fußball zu spielen. Von dem der Satz überliefert ist, kein Gegentor ist schon mal mindestens ein Punkt.
War ganz lange bei St. Etienne vorher?
Genau, war ganz lange bei St. Etienne vorher. Kann aber gut mit Spielern, ist auch ein guter Menschenführer. Und der hat es offenbar geschafft, diese Jungs alle in die Spur zu bringen. Und, ja, spielt jetzt, lässt jetzt tollen Fußball spielen. Die Mannschaft hat sich ganz wunderbar gefunden. Der Thiago Mendes im Mittelfeld, Brasilianer ist auch sehr, sehr wichtig, ist ein sehr uneigennütziger zentraler Spieler, der schnell nach vorne weitergibt, wo sie dann die guten Stimme nach vorne verarbeiten können. José Fonte ist neu dazugekommen, 34, aus Portugal, in der Innenverteidigung, der ganz, ganz viel Gelassenheit auch ausstrahlt, der das alles wieder da mehr Sicherheit reingebracht hat, der auch den jungen Torwart, 23-jährigen Meng Nong, viel mehr Stabilität gegeben hat. Der spielt auch wahnsinnig auf. Die haben eine richtig schöne zentrale Achse, die da richtig stabil steht. Und vorne halt Leute, die Schwindel spielen. Also, Pépé hat beim 13.0 gegen Marseille quasi allein auseinandergenommen. Und das Problem ist halt, wenn du dich auf einen von den drei konzentrierst, schlägt halt mindestens einer der anderen zu aktuell.
Ja, interessant. Pépé, ein rechtsaußen, ein junger rechtsaußen in einer der europäischen Top-League. Da hör ich doch meinen FC Bayern-Ohr sofort auf. Aber gut, lass mir da mal...
Viel Spaß beim Poker mit, ich weiß nicht, wer alles da in Verbindung gebracht worden ist, Manchester United und...
Ja, da glaube ich an die harten Verhandlungskünste von Braco Salihamidzic. Lasst uns lieber weitermachen und mal über Monaco sprechen. Denn entgegen der gängigen Erwartungen findet man die gar nicht an der Tabellenspitze. Wir müssen runtergehen bis auf den 18. Tabellenplatz in dieser mit 20 Teams besetzten Liga, bis wir Monaco finden. Erst ein Sieg, 9 zu 13 Tore, 6 Punkte nach 9 Spieltagen. Was zur Hölle ist denn da los?
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter mit Nimes.
Nein, also man muss halt dazu wissen, ich bin ja Sympathisan von Monaco. Mein Cousin hat ja da gespielt, war der erste französische Verein, mit dem ich Kontakt hatte. Auch damals, als ich in Paris studiert hab, ja, das war die große Meistersaison von Monaco 99 2000. Insofern liegen die mir durchaus am Herzen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch etwas gebiast. Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung. Also was klar war von vorneherein, war, dass ein Umbruch stattfindet bei ihnen. Sie waren ja dieser grandiose Meister. Haben ja auch in der Champions League ganz wunderbaren Fußball gespielt damals mit der Mannschaft. Mit eben Bape, mit Bernardo Silva, mit Fabinho, mit Bakayoko und so weiter und so weiter. Und die sind alle weg. Also mit Fabinho und Lemar sind jetzt quasi die letzten zwei aus dieser großartigen Generation gegangen. Es stimmt nicht ganz, die Innenverteidigung ist noch da. Mit Gemma ist nur ein Glück. Aber es war klar, da kommt ein Umbruch und da wird was Neues sein. Das ist ja auch Monacos System seit einigen Jahren, dass sie junge Spieler verpflichten, sehr schlau scouten. Der Name dahinter bei dieser ersten Generation war übrigens Louis Campos, der ist zu Lille gewechselt. Sie haben grandiose Talente im Kader. Golovin ist da gelandet, der dürfte dir als WM Guka noch bekannt sein, Thierry Lemans ist noch immer da, der war dann auf seinen Durchbruch. Du hast einen Grand Sire, du hast Joe Vetic, du hast Aho Lu, der bei Straßburg letzte Saison groß war. Du hast Henrys verpflichtet.
Genau, von Leverkusen.
Von Leverkusen. Du hast einen Goebbels von Lyon geholt, wo die Lyon-Fans sehr sauer waren, als er da gegangen ist. Du hast den Pelegri, ein ganz großes Talent aus Italien, der als teuerster 16-Jähriger vor ein paar Jahren verpflichtet wurde von Monaco, das war noch so eine durchgewieselte Nummer, weil du eigentlich so junge Spieler nicht verpflichten darfst.
Und Goebbels ist doch auch erst 16.
Kann sein, ja. Aber für den ist wahrscheinlich nicht so viel Geld geflossen. Also damals war das ein großer Aufblick.
transfermarkt.de 20 Millionen Euro. Aber gut, da weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, wie sicher da transfermarkt.de ist.
Also jedenfalls war das mit Pelegri die Geschichte, dass du eigentlich nur dann verpflichten darfst, wenn deine Eltern quasi aus Jobgründen an den Ort ziehen. Und dann sind halt die Eltern von Pelegri aus Jobgründen nach Monaco gezogen.
Ja, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sie da einen schönen Job auf einmal gefunden haben. Ja, und so hat Monaco ja auch den jüngsten Kader der gesamten Liga. Also ein sehr großer Kader, 34 Spieler, gleichzeitig 34 Legionäre und ein Durchschnittseiter von 23,7 Jahren. Damit liegt man an der Spitze.
Wobei sie in der Startelf durchaus noch ein paar Veteranen haben. Also Falcao spielt da immer noch rum. Und wie gesagt, Glick ist auch nicht mehr der jüngste.
30, stimmt.
Also von Glick und Jammer bin ich überrascht enttäuscht. Die sind richtig schlecht. Glick war ja immer der ganz große Abräumer. Jamerson der durchaus der Ballverteiler. Kann sein, dass Glick auch einfach aus der WM müde zurückgekommen ist. Aber... Also Jadim hat es bislang nicht geschafft, diesem Team eine Struktur zu geben. Er weiß nicht genau, wo Erthielemanns hinsetzen soll. Er weiß nicht, wen er einsetzen soll. Es gibt alles Gründe. Es gab Verletzungspech. Du kannst sagen, die brauchen Zeit, um sich einzugewöhnen. Wie du sagst, das sind junge Leute. Aber das sind auch junge Leute, bei denen der Großleister schon in Ahnenzellmannschaften spielt. Also ich... Insofern... Es mag sicher eine psychologische Spirale sein, die da mit reinspielt. Jadim scheint... selbst ratlos. So hab ich ihn auch nicht erlebt. Ich halte sehr viel von Jadim. Ich halte ihn für einen unglaublich unterschätzten Trainer, der viel zu selten bislang auftaucht, wenn große Clubs neue Trainer suchen. Er hat überragend das geschafft mit Monaco in den letzten Jahren. Und immer wieder auch gerade mit jungen Leuten. Aber... Also heute tauchte gerade die Meldung über einen Ticker auf, dass offenbar sein Job bedroht ist. Und jetzt, gerade Velle Stunde vor der Aufnahme, tauchte bereits die Nachfolgemeldung auf, dass Favorit für die Nachfolge Thierry Henry sei.
Spannend.
Ähm, der bei Bordeaux im Gespräch war, zu Anfang der Saison, aber dann da nicht genommen wurde.
Ich frag nur so.
Glaube nicht. Für Leberkuchen, Mann.
Stuttgart hat ja heute verkündet.
Vielleicht kann Jadim Deutsch lernen, obwohl Jadim kann gut mit Jungen.
Ich mein, wir konnten das ja auch mit verfolgen. Jeder, der die Champions League näher betrachtet, da gab es eine Heimniederlage gegen Atletico und jetzt eben das 0 zu 3 gegen Dortmund. Da konnte man schon mal Monaco sehen. Da fand ich aber gegen Dortmund und Monaco gerade in der ersten Halbzeit gar nicht so schlecht. Ich wusste da schon über die schlechte Tabellensituation, dass es der 18. war, war mir damals nicht klar, aber dass es nicht so läuft. Da fand ich eine Halbzeit Monaco eigentlich ganz okay. Was glaubst du, wie wird sich das jetzt drehen können? Würde sich das noch drehen können ohne Trainerwechsel?
Ja, das ist vermutlich die alte Frage bei immer solchen Sachen. Klar kannst du sagen, vielleicht bringt ein neuer Trainer auch dann die berühmten neuen Impulse. Vielleicht schaut er mit einem frischen Blick drauf. Vielleicht ist Jadim da auch gehemmt durch irgendwelche, die dazu lange da ist. Ich weiß es nicht, aber die Zeichen scheinen ja deutlich drauf zu stehen. Es ist noch mal von dem Talent, das da auf dem Platz steht, ist das alles kein Grund, warum das nicht funktionieren sollte. Weil ja, die mögen jung sein, aber bei der Mannschaft, die in Nizza jetzt am Wochenende auf dem Platz stand, waren zwei Leute älter als 26, als 25 sogar.
In Rennes war es, glaube ich.
Und zwar inklusive der Einwechselspieler. Also es gibt auch andere Mannschaften, die jung sind. Ja, die müssen sich alle neu zusammenfinden, klar. Aber also, 18. ist... Es gibt sehr viele Trainer, die Jadim beneiden würden, für diese Spieler, die er auf dem Platz hat, französische Trainer.
Das fasst es vielleicht ganz gut zusammen. Außerdem hast du mir vor der Aufnahme schon gesagt, wir haben ein bisschen abgesprochen, über welche Vereine wir zuerst sprechen wollen, dass du gerne ein paar Worte zu Olympique Neym verlieren würdest. Die sind Aufsteiger und liegen als Aufsteiger auf Tabellenplatz 14. Das heißt aktuell komfortable vier Punkte vor der Abstiegszone. Was macht denn Neym so erwähnenswert?
Also erst mal die Art und Weise, wie sie aufgestiegen sind. Sie hatten damals schon ein unglaublich kleines Budget in der zweiten Liga. Obwohl sie aufgekauft worden waren von einem Geschäftsmann, das nebenbei bemerkt, gibt es, glaube ich, keinen physischen Club, der nicht einem Geschäftsmann gehört. In dem Fall ist es der Erfinder, der Freebox. Das ist so ein Modem-Setup-Box-Verschnitt. Also so ein Internetprovider-Ding ins Moment. Und der scheint den Club auch so wie ein Start-up zu führen, mit bewusst wenig Personal und durchaus geringen Garschen, die die Spieler verdienen.
Aber abends beteiligt er sich am Sushi, was man dann ruht, wenn Überschritte gemacht werden.
Richtig? Neymar ist ein Club schon mit einem gewissen Mythos. Die hatten ihre große Zeit in den 50er-Jahren. Ich bin ja auch Fußballdeutsch sozialisiert. Für mich fängt ja Fußball auch erst richtig 1962 an. Vorher gab es halt irgendwelche Oberligen und diverse Meisterschaften, aber das ist ja alles nicht richtig. Und Frankreich merkt schon, dass die länger eine Liga haben, wo es halt wirklich auch Geschichten gibt. Also 50er-Jahre waren Reims und Nimes, haben sich große Schlachten um der Bellenspitze geliefert. Reims war ja die, die sogar dann europäisch gegen Madrid aufgelaufen sind und so weiter und so weiter. Insofern ist es ein Name. War normalerweise 30 oder 25 Jahre nicht mehr in der ersten Liga. Und spielen, kommen aus einer eher fußballverrückten Region.
In der Nähe vom Marseille und Marseille.
Genau. Und sind auch eher so ein bisschen Arbeiterstadt. Und spielen einen, für einen Aufsteiger, erfrischenden, hurra-offensiv orientierten Fußball. Also, eine Mischung aus... Also, sie laufen viel, sie ackern viel. Das ist dann eher so dieses Darmstadt-Element. Aber es gibt dann neue Spieler, die nach Neymar kommen und sich dann wundern, warum sie mit dem Training so viel laufen müssen und sagen, ja, das ist bei uns so, das macht man bei uns so. Aber gleichzeitig nutzen sie eben diese Physis nicht, um sich hinten reinzustellen oder den Ball hinterher zu laufen, sondern um hoch zu pressen teilweise. Neymar hat Marseille auseinandergenommen, unter anderem 3-1 gegen Marseille gewonnen. Und wie gesagt, haben auch gegen Paris durchaus gar nicht schlecht ausgesehen. Also wenn Leute mal reinschauen wollen in die französische Liga, man kann sich durchaus ein Spiel mit niemanden schauen. Das Stadion ist immer voll, die Leute machen da ganz schön Stimmung auch. Das ist ein sympathischer Verein, finde ich. Wie gesagt, haben auch viele junge Leute. Klar, sind trotzdem noch Aufsteiger. Also muss man jetzt auch nicht überbewerten. Die werden da sicherlich nicht die spitze Labelle stürmen. Aber ist eine sehr schöne Story, auf die man mal aufmerksam machen kann in diesem Medium hier.
Ja, vielen herzlichen Dank dafür. Mit Olympique Neym wäre ich jetzt nicht unbedingt ums Eck gekommen. Jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Minuten, die du zur freien Verfügung hast aus all den tollen Vereinen mit ihren vielen Geschichten in der Liga, die es noch so gibt. Wem würdest du denn noch so herauspicken und würdest sagen, die sind so erwähnenswert, dass du da jetzt ein paar Worte drüber verlieren möchtest?
Also, ich muss ganz kurz noch mal auch Straßburg erwähnen. Und zwar, weil ich da war vor zwei Wochen, als sie gegen die Jean gespielt haben. Und ich kann jedem, der irgendwie in der Region wohnt, nicht zu weit von Straßburg, wirklich nur empfehlen, da mal Ground Topping zu machen. Das ist eine absolut Bombenstimmung in dem Stadion. Die Osttribüne war es, glaube ich. Also da, wo die Ultras stehen, das sind eigentlich Stehplätze.
Aber die Ultras sitzen.
Die waren anderthalb Stunden, als wir jetzt in den Stadion kamen, relativ früh war eineinhalb Stunden vorher die Tribüne schon komplett gefüllt mit Leuten auf diesen Sitzplätzen eben. Und das ganze Spiel über haben die gestanden auf den Sitzplätzen. Und haben als Stimmung gemacht. Und zwar, also die müssen sich nicht verstecken vor diversen deutschen Vereinen. Das war ziemlich großartig. Und ich fand auch, das Team hatte durchaus, da war Technik drin. Also da waren kleine Doppelpässe drin, da waren Pässe drin, die mit der Hacke geschlagen wurden.
Und die waren doch schon letzte Saison gar nicht so schlecht. Die waren auch letzte Saison auch schon als Aufsteiger damals im Mittelfeld der Liga.
Ja, genau. Also für den Aufsteiger. Und haben dann einen grandiosen, denkwürdigen Spiel gegen Lyon. Klassener hat es geschafft mit einem Tor von Léon Arche. Also haben auch durchaus spannende Leute, den Spiegelstalter Thomason, 24, französisch-kroate, Sissoko, kraftvoller zentraler defensiver Mittelfeldspieler, Motiba, 22, aus Südafrika, kam neu von Lille, Kevin Sohi, 21, Elfenbeinküste aus der eigenen Jugend, das fanden wir, hat uns sehr gefallen, war sehr quirlig. Also auch, wie gesagt, du merkst schon, ich glaub, die französische Liga verkauft sich mittlerweile selbst als die Liga der Talente. Mir fällt tatsächlich auf, dass wo immer ich zuschaue, fast immer stehen irgendwelche Leute auf dem Platz, die U23 sind. Und zwar in einer Häufigkeit, die mir so in Deutschland, in der Bundesliga nicht unterkommt, obwohl ja auch die Bundesligisten durchaus gerade in den letzten Jahren das verstärkt machen.
Ja, wobei auch gerade die Bundesliga viele französische Spiele ja jetzt sich geholt hat in den letzten Jahren. Das haben wir hier in der Schlusskonferenz auch schon mal festgehalten. Also umso erstaunlicher, dass da immer wieder neue Talente, nachwachsene ich jetzt fast gesagt, aber herangezogen werden können, wieder an den Profifußball. Okay, also wir speichern ab. Straßburg ist eine Reise wert. Kann man mal ins Stadion gehen. Zu wem lohnt sich denn vielleicht noch ein Kurztrip nach Frankreich?
Willzeit haben wir noch. Acht Minuten circa, okay gut.
Also wenn ich mir jetzt was rauspicken müsste, dann würde ich dich fragen, warum Montpellier so gut dasteht. Aktuell auf Platz 4. Also es verwundert mich jetzt nicht komplett, dass die weit oben sind, aber das scheint alles sehr solide zu sein, mit erst einer Niederlage, 12 erzielten Toren und 7 Kassierten.
Ja, genau. Also Montpellier ist eine Mannschaft, die schon in der vergangenen Saison ein Prunkstück Defensive hat. Das ist sogar fast historisch bei ihnen. Du kannst mal raten, wer der All-Time-Topscorer für Montpellier ist, mit 84 Toren. Puh, du kennst ihn.
Es muss ein Defensivmann sein, wenn du das schon so einleitest. Tja, das könnte ja jeder sein.
Ja, es ist Laurent Blanc. Laurent Blanc, der damals eigentlich noch deutlich offensiver gespielt hat, wohlgemerkt. Also sonst hätte er doch keine 84 Tore geschossen zwischen 83 und 91. War er da, wurde er erst 89 dann zum Libero nach hinten gezogen. Aber die waren durchaus immer gut, aber haben jetzt es geschafft, eben noch zwei echte Stürmer zu verpflichten und unterstützt durch eine klassische Nummer 10, durch Molay. Was ihnen viel, viel mehr Durchschlag bringt. Der Torwart Le Comte ist ein absoluter Superstar auch schon mittlerweile geworden. Hat in diversen Fantasy-Football-Meneda spielen einen unglaublich hohen Marktwert.
Da wird vielleicht auch gerade der FC Augsburg hellhörig geworden sein. Ich kann irgendwie nicht umhin bei der französischen Liga ständig dran zu denken, zu welchen Bundesligisten die Spieler wechseln könnten.
Und sie haben mit Hilton, dem Brasilianer, ein unglaubliches Unikat in der Innenverteidigung. Der ist 41 Jahre alt. Der hat damals schon die Meisterschaft mit Montpellier gefeiert. Und ich glaube, es kommt mit Marseille.
Unglaublich. Im nächsten Jahr wird er sein 20.
Profi-Jahr anbrechen. Ja, und er ist tatsächlich immer noch... Also, er ist noch ziemlich agil. Er wirkt nicht wie jemand, der überfordert ist. Das ist echt beeindruckend. Sie sind hinten stabil. Sie haben auch einen Trainer, der von den Fans Armenischer Mourinho genannt wird.
Ach komm, wenn jeder Trainer der Armenischer Mourinho genannt wird, auch wirklich einer wäre dann...
Er hat den verwirrenden Namen Der Zakarian. Und das verwirrt mich als Deutscher immer fürchterlich, weil dieses Der ist ein eigener Namensbestandteil. Und ich lese halt immer Der, also der so und so.
Aber was macht ihn denn zu Mourinho? Also Mourinho hat ja viele Eigenschaften. Welche davon qualifizieren denn dazu, der armenische Mourinho zu werden?
Na, wie gesagt, eher die, dass er defensiv spielen lässt.
Ach so, aber nicht Selbstbewusstsein, Umgang mit der Presse, Werbeverträge, Trophäenschrank?
Er ist nicht für Spektakel bekannt. Und ich meine mich auch zu erinnern, dass Montpellier, also sie gewinnen immer eher 1-0 oder 2-1 und zittern sich noch durch die Endphase, als dass sie wirklich mal entscheidend mit 13 oder 14-0 gewinnen.
Okay, also schauen wir uns nicht an, wenn wir Spektakel haben wollen, aber definitiv.
Ja, wie gesagt, also durch diese neue Stürmer-Paarung mit Laborde und Delors, sie stehen da oben, ne? Also, wie viele Tore haben sie jetzt?
Ich hab auch hier noch die Seite offen mit den Schüssen pro Spiel, und da ist jetzt Montpellier auf Platz 9 in der Liga. Da führt übrigens Olympique Lyon, und zwar mit weitem Vorsprung vor Lille und PSG. Also, die schießen häufiger aufs Tor als die erfolgreichste.
Ja, Olympique Lyon kann man sich definitiv anschauen, wenn man möchte, zumindest wenn sie einen guten Tag haben. Die haben möglicherweise eins der talentiertesten Mittelfelder. Ich weiß nicht, ich will jetzt nicht zu großartig werden, aber weit über die Liga hinaus, sag ich mal.
Stehen die aber nur oft Platz 6?
Ja, weil Talent heißt nicht unbedingt, dass du jedes Spiel gewinnst. Außerdem haben sie gerade einen 5-0 gegen Paris, sich in Klatsche eingefangen, dass sie nach der ersten Halbzeit nicht unbedingt hätten verlieren müssen. Da rechnen die drei Punkte drauf, dann stehen sie auf Platz 3.
Das Pressing, das du vorhin erzählt hattest.
Diese Tabelle ist sehr eng da gerade. Da gibt es eigentlich unter diesen Platz 2 bis 8, sag ich mal, waren in den vergangenen Wochen fast jeder von denen hat mal auf dem Podium rumgeschnuppert. Man ist wieder nach unten gefallen. Aber die drei Namen, die man sich bei Lyon merken kann, von denen ich glaube, dass sie auch demnächst irgendwann in ein paar Jahren bei Top Clubs spielen werden, sind Toussaint. Aoua, Hussein Aoua, technisch präzise, kann Rhythmus bestimmen, weiß nicht, wie man ein Spiel beschleunigt. Und Don Bellet, der jetzt von Deschamps in den Nationalelf verrufen worden ist. Absolut enormer Mann auch. Und davor hast du dann noch jemanden wie Traoré. Du hast Musa Dembelé gekauft, der erst mal nur Ersatzspieler war, aber auch, wenn er gespielt hat, durchaus gezeigt hat, was er kann. Du hast Fekir gehalten, was niemand gedacht hätte. Der war eigentlich schon in Liverpool gefühlt. Dann gab es irgendein seltsames, angeblich war es ein Medizin-Check, der irgendwie schiefgelaufen ist.
Man weiß die Pei spielt noch bei Lyon.
Genau, man weiß die Pei spielt. Aber der muss richtig kämpfen gegen diese Konkurrenz.
Bitte sag mir, dass er gegen Martin, ich spreche ihn jetzt extra so aus, Thierrya kämpfen muss.
Ja, weil er irgendwie die Waden beißt. Ja, Thierrya war einer der großartigen Spieler von Straßburg letztes Jahr und ist auch überraschend gut angekommen bei Lyon. Also ist ja auch noch relativ jung, 21. Insofern, die haben da Talent, die haben da tolle Spieler. Ihr Trainer ist immer so ein bisschen unter dem Verdacht, nicht gut genug zu sein, weil er halt kein großer Name ist, weil er aus dem Dunstkreis des Präsidenten kommt, weil er schon ewig im Club ist. Und der Präsident immer versprochen hat, dass Lyon einen Trainer bekommt, der seiner Statur würdig ist, der der Statur des Clubs würdig ist.
Und das hat Bruno Genesio offensichtlich nicht.
Na ja, wie gesagt, der ist halt kein Weltklasse-Name.
Bruno ist ziemlich vielversprechend für einen Trainer.
Ja, und er hat Guardiola entzaubert. Also das Spiel gegen Man City war herausragend, was sie da geleastet haben.
Ja, richtig, ich erinnere mich, das hatte ich gerade schon wieder komplett verdrängt. Ja, da sieht man nämlich mal, das war der Auswärtssieg zum Auftakt in die Champions League 2-0, wenn ich mich nicht erinnere.
Genau, und dann liegen sie gegen Schachter, Donetsk, gegen Schachter, also liegen sie in 2-0 zurück und schaffen noch ein 2-2.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Ja, ich erinnere mich an Lyon. Weißt du, welcher Club mich noch immer besonders interessiert in der Ligue 1? Und es hat mit einem Wechsel zu tun, St. Etienne. Seitdem Neven Subotic da spielt und ich dazu begleitend ihn in Au-Four-Oren gehört habe, wie er erzählt hat, wie er sich für diesen Club entschieden hat, habe ich, glaube ich, verstanden zu haben, ein bisschen eher, was für ein Verein St. Etienne ist und was für ein Fanumfeld da hat und auch welche Art von Fußball man da spielen will. Und jetzt schaue ich auf die Tabelle und sehe ein gemischt durchwachsener Start, aber nicht negativ. Also vier Siege, drei Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen, elf zu zwölf Tore, aktuell Platz fünf. Aber du hast ja schon vorhin richtigerweise gesagt, das ist alles sehr eng gerade. Wie läuft für die so?
Ich muss eine Gegenfrage stellen, von wann war die Folge? Die klingt interessant, die will ich hören.
Die war im Sommer, als er gewechselt ist. Da werde ich einfach verlinken und dir noch mal schinken. Ich packe sie auf jeden Fall in die Show Notes. War sehr interessant, auch weil er erzählt hat, dass er dann verschiedene Kriterien sich ausgesucht hat, nach denen er den Verein entscheiden wollte. Dann hat er die in eine Tabelle eingefügt und hat dann nach einem Punktesystem entschieden, zu welchem Verein er gehen will. Fand ich super. Das kam auch meiner Arbeitsweise total entgegen. Totale Statistik. Und dann ist ja Supertisch sowieso in allem, was er tut, großartig. Deswegen eine wirklich tolle Folge schicke ich dir sehr gerne.
Also die Geschichte ist, dass sie in der Vorsaison waren sie defensiv stark, aber mit so einer alternden, eher müden Angriffsabteilung. Und da wurde dann gezielt nachgelegt mit Kasri, mit Kabea auch. Und auch die hatten den Trainer gewechselt. Da führt jetzt der 64-jährige Garcet-Regie, der eher so ein paternalistischer älterer Herr ist, der seine Spieler, meine Kinder oder meine Kleinen nennt. Aber anscheinend auch durchaus auch da wieder gut ist im Management, im Spielermanagement, und der vor allem ganz großes Netzwerk hat, weil er die rechte Hand war lange, lange Zeit von L'En Blanc. Und der hat dann so ehemalige Größen nach St. Etienne geholt wie M. Villard und so weiter. Das heißt, das Team ist eine Mischung aus jungen Leuten und so gestandenen Profis, sind so einige Namen, wo man denkt, Hoppla, das waren doch mal aufstrebende Spieler, die es dann vielleicht nicht ganz so geschafft haben. Das Problem von St. Etienne ist, dass sie eigentlich zum Erfolg verdammt sind. Weil sie haben ihr Budget aufgepumpt auf 74 Millionen Euro und das Budget um 25 Prozent aufgebläht.
Woher weiß man das so genau?
Weil die Präsidenten das erzählt haben und weil die Präsidenten den Club verkaufen wollen, den Club, die beiden Besitzer zum Ende des Jahres. Der Verkauf war im Mai schon mal gescheitert. Ein interessierter Investor, das Problem ist, das ist so eine Braut mit so ein paar Flecken auf dem Brautkleid. Die sind unter anderem nichtbesitzer ihrer eigenen Stadions. Und 22 Prozent des Vermögens des Clubs sind noch in der Hand der Justiz, weil ein Anteilseigner wegen Betrugsverurteilung wurde. Und die Präsidenten sagen, sie wollen nach dem Verkauf gerne noch zwei Jahre im Amt bleiben jeweils. Das macht es auch.
Legen wir auch noch mal ab unter Argumente für 50 plus 1.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt gerade in der Schwebe. Und vor allen Dingen hatten wir, wann war das denn Anfang des Jahres, glaube ich, sind die neuen Fernsehrechte verkauft worden von Frankreich. Und die sind für einen ziemlich großen Batzen rumgegangen. Das heißt, ab 2020 fließt eh nochmal richtig Asche in die französische Liga. Und dadurch ist der Verkauf jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr so ganz so dringend, weil es kommt ja bald Geld. Aber sie haben offenbar ein Kredit aufgenommen über 25 Millionen Euro mit teilweise ziemlich hohen Zinsen. Und wenn St. Etienne irgendwie bis 2020 absteigen sollte, wenn irgendwas irgendwie ganz schlecht läuft, dann haben sie ein richtiges Problem. Weil dann werden sie das alles nicht bedienen können. Das ist übrigens auch etwas, was Lille beinahe 2017 passiert wäre. Die wurden auch dann aufgekauft von einem Geschäftsmann. Also insofern, ja, St. Etienne steht gut da, spielen auch interessant. Aber haben so ein bisschen finanzielle Drogen im Nacken, dass sie das tatsächlich machen müssen. Und ebenso wie einige der anderen Clubs, was ich eben schon gesagt hab. Du hast immer wieder Spiele gehabt, da waren sie großartig. Und du hast Spiele gehabt, da kam dann nichts. Also gerade der von dir angesprochene Subotic hatte durchaus auch schwankende Leistungen zuletzt. Kabea auch. Haben dann auch mit ganz jungen Leuten plötzlich herum experimentiert. Modern ist aufgetaucht im Kader. Selnaes ist auch ein ganz spannender Typ. Der kommt aus Norwegen, der kam 2016 als angeblich bester Spieler der norwegischen Liga. Konnte das aber dann lang Zeit nicht zeigen.
Immer das heiße Mark. Wir erinnern uns an Ödegard.
Wo ist er eigentlich jetzt?
Kann ich dir nicht mal aus dem Stand sagen. Läuft sowohl bei ihm als auch bei mir. Er spielt bei Vitesse Arnheim. Na gucken wir mal. Da steht vielleicht dann mal ein Wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus in der Ähre de Vise? Kurzpas an.
Oder in der norwegischen Liga.
Ich scoute die Talente, bevor sie zu Talenten in Frankreich werden. Mal gucken, wie abgespaced das noch werden wird. Es steht und fällt mit den Gästen. Und da warst du ein ganz hervorragender, David. Vielen herzlichen Dank. Wir haben, glaube ich, selten in einem Kurzpass zu einer Liga so viele unterschiedliche Vereine untergebracht. Eine große Freude, da mit dir drüber zu sprechen. Danke dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Ja, sehr gerne. Und die anrüchige Geschichte hebe ich mir dann für 3.90 auf. Und mach dann noch mal Werbung für dich dann.
Sehr gut. 3.90. Hört 3.90. Und das war jetzt auch ein wirklich sehr professioneller, ich ziehe meinen Hut, Cliffhanger und Teaser. Dass man auch bei 3.90 reinhört. Man kann dir folgen auf Twitter als ettengonggongvn. Wir werden jetzt nicht dir das mal erklären, warum du so heißt. Aber man wird dich schon finden, ist auch verlinkt. Und dann machen wir es doch so, ich veröffentliche jetzt die Folge. Und du hörst das Auf-Wür-Ohren-Gespräch zu Neven Subotic. Werde ich dir gleich den Link schicken. Dann vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr könnt uns unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Und wie immer gilt, schon ein Euro, schon zwei Euro im Monat reichen. Das heißt, überleg das doch mal.